il s'est prononcé spécifiquement sur la
question de l'hydroxyde chloroquine le
haut conseil recommande de ne pas
utiliser ce traitement
en l'absence de recommandations à
l'exception de formes graves
hospitalière sur décision collégiale des
médecins est sous surveillance médicale
strictes enfin le haut-conseil exclut
toute prescription dans la population
générale ou pour des formes non sévère à
ce stade
en l'absence dit il de toutes données
probantes
suivant cet avis des scientifiques
je prendrais dans les prochaines heures
un arrêté venant encadrer l'utilisation
hors à mêmes c'est à dire en dehors des
autorisations classique de
commercialisation des médicaments pour
l'hydro xi chloroquine qui sera donc
désormais accessible aux équipes
médicales hospitalières qui le
souhaitent dans les conditions prévues
je le rappelle pour des malades
hospitalisés avec des formes sévères sur
décision collégiale des médecins